[Musique]
donc
donc nous les jetons là où nous voyons qu'il y
a beaucoup de destruction
de sorte que nous nous attendons à ce qu'une autre nouvelle forêt repousse, c'est parce que nous avons besoin d'avoir la
forêt ici
pour que les éléphants qui sont ici  peut
réellement
obtenir de la nourriture et un habitat
[Musique]
des vacances [
Musique]
dans la nature lorsque vous jetez simplement
des graines nues, beaucoup de ces graines sont mangées par les
souris, les oiseaux et les insectes, nous
les protégeons donc dans la poussière de charbon de bois
afin que vous puissiez les jeter toute l'année  ronde, vous
n'avez pas besoin d'attendre la saison des pluies,
elle restera là recouverte de ce
petit revêtement protecteur,
attendez que les pluies arrivent qui
enlèvent la poussière et ensuite la graine revient
à son état naturel et peut démarrer
[Musique]
[Musique] pousse
et ces arbres fournissent comme une éponge, donc
la pluie tombe, frappe les arbres,
puis descend sur les troncs des
arbres et se diffuse lentement dans le
sol,
donc ce qui est super important de ce
point de vue, c'est quand
si vous n'avez pas  qu'ensuite l'eau
tombe directement sur le sol et
lave la surface du sol et
arrache toute la terre du
dessous
[Musique]
vous